le 14 novembre 1986 sylvie aubert
employée dans un supermarché de chalon
quitte son travail et regagne en
cyclomoteur le domicile de ses parents à
saint loup de varennes
après cinq mois d'intenses recherches le
corps de la jeune caissière est retrouvé
par des promeneurs au bord de la deûle
on retrouve sylvie aubert les poignets
liés par du fil de fer elle et dévêtue
et puis le corps est effectivement très
dégradé une longue enquête commence et
les années passent jusqu'à ce
rebondissement vingt ans plus tard en
un tueur en série allemand intéresse la
justice française il s'agit d'une riche
munsterman identifié grâce à un
témoignage
le témoignage qui relance la piste
munsterman c'est celui d'une collègue
caissière de sylvie aubert elle a
reconnu le suspect munsterman aurait
partagé parfois la pause déjeuner de la
jeune femme
les enquêteurs disposent également
d'autres témoignages attestant de la
présence dans la région de
chalon-sur-saône du véhicule d'ulrich
muenstermann un camping-car blanc et
bleu les enquêteurs français se déplace
en allemagne mais le tueur en série nie
les faits et les investigations s'arrête
la piste munsterman ne donnera jamais
rien